- It's Z-I, Z-A-C-H, Zach.
And we're done.
(upbeat music)
Hey, what's up, y'all.
Since the Scribd spelling bee was canceled
due to the pandemic,
Anthony Anderson and I
are competing with the would be contenders
in the first annual Kelly's Spellies.
Get it?
Today on the show.
I know you get it.
The contestants will tackle
typical Scribds bee words,
but Anthony and I have to spell
the names of famous people.
I obviously need to win,
so I'm doing a practice round right now.
Let's do this.
(upbeat music)
Okay. First up, Jake Gyllenhaal.
J-A-K-E.
(audience laughs)
G-I-L... Gyllen...
G-I-L-L-E-N-H-A-L-L.
(buzzer buzzes)
Gyllenhaal.
(beep)
Or, shoot. Oh, is there?
Oh, there's a cheating?
Oh, okay. I was way off.
Samsonite. I was way off.
(upbeat music)
This is Scarlett Johansson.
So, I'm going to say S-C-A-R-L-E-T.
(buzzer buzzes)
Nailed it.
No? T, T-T.
I didn't, you didn't
let me finish, Chrissy.
That was just rude.
I wasn't finished.
So I was seeing if you
knew that there were two Ts
'cause there are in Scarlett Johansson.
So, T-T.
Johansson.
It's capital J-O.
Johansson. A-N-S-O-N?
(buzzer buzzes)
Okay.
(accordion music)
And next up, we have Timothee Chalamet.
Very dashing.
T-O-M-O-T-H-Y, Timothy.
(buzzer buzzes)
Maybe it's two Es, or, where is he from?
Timothy... Oh, he is?
Oh, Timothee.
So, if it's French, then is it C-H?
Woo! I feel really good about that.
Chalamet. Oh my God.
The end is gonna have like five vowels.
C-H-A-L-O-M-E-A-U-O-U-E-U-O.
(buzzer buzzes)
I feel like all French words have, like,
five vowels at the end,
and it's like, eaeu.
I don't know.
Oh, and he had a fancy Timothee Chalamet.
Oh yeah. That does seem
right now that you see it.
But wouldn't it have been
cool the way I saw it?
- [Producer] Do you know you
spelled it T-O-M-O, Tomothy?
- Tomothee?
- [Producer] No, that's
how you spelled it.
- Oh, I did?
Oh, I meant I.
(producers laugh and speak)
I actually meant I.
(upbeat jingly music)
- This is Macaulay Culkin, and nope.
(she laughs)
I don't, I've even, like,
retweeted him before,
and this is all I've got.
Ah!
All I know is Macauley Culkin.
Macaulay, M-C.
(buzzer buzzes)
No, of course not.
Macaulay. I don't, I don't know.
(bell rings)
That's how you spell it?
Culkin. I've never really
thought about that.
Culkin. That's an interesting last name.
(upbeat music)
I love him.
This is Zach Galifianakis.
So, how you spell his name
is Z-I, Z-A-C-H, Zach.
And we're done.
(audience laughs)
Galifianakis? G-A-L-I-F...
Galifianak, Galifian, I-N-A-T-K-I-S?
I don't know.
Oh! I was close!
It's the Greek in me.
(upbeat music)
All right, so here we have Shia LaBeouf,
and I'm going to say S-H-I-A.
LaBeouf. Maybe it's French, LaBeouf.
LaBeouf.
L-E-B-O-U-F.
(buzzer buzzes)
I don't know.
Oh, I was not far. Okay.
Oh, la. I just feel
like it's always le, le.
And then every time you do the thing
on Rosetta Stone, she goes, non,
'cause I screw it up.
(upbeat music)
All right, last up.
Beautiful. Classy.
This is Saoirse Ronan.
S-A-O-I-R-S-E R-O-N-A-N.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Yeah.
- [Producer] What, are you cheating?
Are you cheating?
- [Director] I just thought
it'd be a funny way to end it.
- They just told me how to spell it
because these are hard.
Where's, like, Matt Damon?
I'll take Ben Affleck for 500.
I hope I do better on the show, obviously.
Tune in today to see a train wreck.
All right. Pray for me.